knowledge is power they say but in
today's global economy knowledge is more
like a currency the trick is to make it
work for you that's why we want to turn
the European Union into an innovation
union a plan to get good ideas to market
faster to boost the economy create jobs
and improve lives
that's where horizon 2020 comes in
providing the money motivation and
muscle to keep Europe at the forefront
of knowledge and turned good ideas into
innovation for example to find new ways
to keep us healthy help us get around or
protect our environment so how does
horizon 2020 help what's so different
about this 7 year research program it's
been streamlined and simplified we're
not going to bury you in red tape
anymore horizon 2020 is easier to access
for institutes and universities
companies and especially more open to
small businesses and international
partners bigger simpler smarter the
program
is much bigger the EU is investing
nearly 80 billion euros and much simpler
than smarter to manage for you no really
it's now a single neatly woven program
bringing together previously separate
sources of research and innovation
funding horizon 2020 will also be more
in tune with Sciences role in society so
it focuses on challenges we urgently
need to address like clean energy and
recycling caring for the elderly
healthcare food safety and our oceans
real things this challenge based
approach means horizon 2020 is more
flexible as well the research and
innovation is grouped under just three
broad headings or pillars for the
architectural reminded excellent science
and scientists making Europe a magnet
for innovation industrial leadership and
investment in turnkey technologies and
businesses better society with knowledge
and the power to improve lives take the
challenge with horizon 2020 what you see
is what you get but also what you make
of it but getting closer to real
everyday needs like this doesn't mean
basic research is out in the cold that's
the beauty of coupling science and
innovation it covers a much wider range
from research to retail and all forms of
blue sky thinking and innovative
approaches that make this possible
investing in excellent projects and
people anywhere and in any way that
delivers innovation from the lab to the
market much faster than anyone dreamed
possible in Europe that's a real
innovation union and now horizon 2020
makes it really simple it's time to find
out how you can take part bigger simpler
smarter with horizon
20:24 a bright future